la période des fêtes s'annonce encore
une fois coursé cette année mais bonne
nouvelle le virus respiratoire
s'incitial qui se répand de manière
fulgurante chez les enfants aurait
atteint le pic de sa courbe et sa
transmission serait actuellement en
baisse malheureusement la tendance
inverse dans le cas de l'influence à
covid-19 mais on sait que le mois de
décembre devrait être difficile pour les
mutualiser on s'attend à sculpique soit
éteint dans le mois de décembre on est
plus nombreux à l'intérieur en magazine
puis nombreux à l'intérieur on a des
partées de bureau des réceptions comme
ça il y a plus de risques là on se dit
c'est important essayons de tout se
protéger de protéger avec les gestes
barrières habituels comme le port du
masque dans les lieux fermés et
achalandés et la vaccination contre la
grippe et la covid 19 parallèlement aux
urgences qui débordent dans les écoles
du Québec le taux d'absentéisme lui
s'élève à 12,7%,
plus de double de la moyenne préco vide
avec 158000 élèves absents au primaire
au secondaire à la formation
professionnelle et l'éducation des
adultes les parents qui gardent plus
leurs enfants à la maison
on se trouve qu'ils ont des symptômes
donc ils vont le garder plus et l'autre
chose c'est que nos enfants sont plus
fragiles pour après deux ans de pandémie
avec certaines mesures sanitaires dont
le port du masque c'est difficile de
conjuguer tous les jours avec un certain
pourcentage d'élèves absents leur faut
penser envoyer du travail à la maison
s'ajuster le matin même quand on se rend
compte qu'il manque le tiers ou la
moitié d'une classe avec trois virus
respiratoires en circulation la santé
publique demande donc au Québécois de
faire preuve de civisme et de porter le
masque en présence de symptômes alors
qu'un retour du port obligatoire ne
semble pas dans les plans ici Gabriel
prou Radio-Canada MONT